okay one episode of it being garyvee up
in the office who rap crap it will be
before me talked about ownership and
leverage a period sectors that out their
average likes about alternatives like
like everybody who watches this like
when they leave comments like when you
sleep [ __ ] comments by global okay
cool what's the alternative
don't tell me blah blah blah tell me the
[ __ ] out is the other option like don't
be optimistic rate be pessimistic you
know like don't think it's true great
like be cynical like don't want to work
hard great don't work hard like like
don't tell me I'm wrong don't judge you
know like what's the alternatives for me
what's fun is I'm documenting yeah I'm
not creating like I don't do daily be my
job is not getting me I [ __ ] work
like I'm moving I'm doing I'm letting my
actions speak
[Music]
how would you tell somebody to find like
there's like there's nothing let's think
about this question
I tell them right it's like it's like
how do you tell somebody being shaped
like this dude you put in the work
right like hey do sit-ups eat well like
like it's so crazy
everything's very basic it just comes
down to you do it or not I think I think
the reason my contact resonates is I
never waver right like I think a lot of
you know like after a little while like
you get the gist of what I'm about and
then the only reason I think I'm worth
listening to after you figure that part
out is I'm good at trend-spotting and if
you listen to me and watch me you can
pick up on things you can do that will
make your life better but like it only
takes you about if you're smart it takes
you about thirty days to realize like
I'm going to say the same I'm literally
going to say the same [ __ ] for the next
50 years I mean the motivational thing
is real but I think you can get that
other places there's plenty of Instagram
accounts that say go do it I think the
fact that I'm actually doing it and I
don't want anything from you there's a
powerful relationship point but then I
think the longevity comes in that I'm
going to do this around AR and VR and 10
other things that I don't even know are
coming and I think I didn't I mean
Alexis skills and podcasts were around a
year ago they were around I wasn't
interested because I didn't feel the
movement in the market now I do and I
think I think if I if I leave you with
anything like whatever you want to do in
your life it's super important to watch
what I'm doing I have like a really long
track record of being successful on land
grabbing early and getting
disproportionate value out of it and so
you can apply that to yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
which is why I don't like the current
state of entrepreneurship in the world
because it seems very party and popular
and cool and it is literally everything
but I started my daily vlogs yes I like
attention and I want selfies but much
more because I want people to see how
hard it really is how long every day is
if you really want to be successful and
so I'm scared of everything which
actually ironically means I'm scared of
nothing
do you understand me
it's like got it I know it's a funny
little statement but by accepting you
fear of everything it kind of makes me
numb it makes me not fear anything yeah
and awesome remember
[Music]
here are the thing I've learned at Ryde
2017 Gary B likes air quoting and the
word arbitrage really in a very very
dashing to guarantee a point doctor
please give a big welcome to Gary well
thank you guys so much for coming
it's awesome I think everybody here if I
told them everything is going to be ok
you can have everything you want now
what are you going to do with your day I
think a lot of people know it could be
anything if you were to then watch
movies all day like if we played this
game and you're like okay everything
well [ __ ] I don't be [ __ ] I just want to
watch movies cool I think you should
build a business around that right like
to me like great right so like I just
are scared I think people are scared I
think they're scared what people will
think and I think they're scared that
they can't survive living the life that
they want to live from a materialistic
standpoint what makes me so dangerous
because I don't need anything I don't
need anything I don't need anybody and
that's it and so I'm good and and I wish
that on everybody you know nice it is to
not rely on anybody for anything at all
ever not emotionally not financially not
lately it's just a Zen zone but purpose
is to make yourself happy no regrets
thanks again Patrick here ya go
sure you know I got the Bridget to hire
someone and I'm struggling if I hire
someone for e-commerce or someone like a
guy again a do-rag guys with me I would
hire somebody for sales or read the
armors because that will get big a
return that will get more returning
quickly okay which will then allow you
to afford the next thing if you go with
your rock and go branding so you're
going to have to wing correct got it and
you know I'm good for I'm good for stars
actually man I'm good for product design
is that true I need to focus on
something and that now try to improve
nope
with a hate for the show now is this
stuff no okay cool hire somebody for
that right hey man welcome to Uncle
thank you my friend
Carrie I will see you they like one hour
Kristen thank you for everything
sighs thank you bye bye everyone bye bye
[Music]
the obstacle right now that I'm pissed
that nobody takes me up on my open-door
policy
so I'm going to react to it and I'm
going to force every employee to see me
every six months period end of story I
will see them off every employee that's
right you're I was whatever it takes I
will give up all the time I'm going to
give up five minutes five minutes times
800 lots of minutes let me think it is I
think you mentioned I think they have
empathy for me and they think I have
better things to do than here they're
five minutes of the headaches I don't
think they realize but I want to fix
every problem I think they think I'm
like every other one of their managers
in the building that can't fix every
problem so they don't want to hear it I
can fix them all and then other and then
I think cynicism and fear and lack of
self-esteem and they think I care more
about being garyvee than Gary Vaynerchuk
Asiya there's a million reasons I don't
care what the reasons are I need to fix
my concept that's an adversity that will
make me better and that happens every
single day awesome you should thank you
good luck you very much appreciate it
back no don't go that way when Malcolm
awesome perfect echo sorry yes I can
really really do when you're amazing
[Music]
all right it's true okay one episode of
it you pick up the camera now and show
two of our three or four homies that
help us say hello guys these are two two
amazing teammates
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering that cool dude you're like a
thanks for watching subscribe
we're well known over that right sorry
thank you for asking
Daniella I'm very upset because you're
not with us and I fully expected you to
be here first of all here you're badass
entrepreneur so I can't wait to meet you
because look us smiley your partner is
can't wait to meet keep grinding keep
hustling but most importantly recognize
how hardcore of a winner you are and
deploy that confidence from a day in and
day out standpoint see ya
a few hiding or the skulls wearing not
Assad not mean to offend but girl you
can't pretend no no I never feel trying
to recharge connecting with the wall not
wanting to nothing but girl you can't
leave no no I tell you like teaching
cookie hi
I guess if you like it thank you so much
thank you awesome I love it
thank you brother - thank you thank you
that's good thank you
alright okay come on then I started
investing in what happened was I
invested in Twitter and Facebook and a
lot of crazy things started happening
okay and now I run a very large social
media agency 800 people okay but I still
the family still owns the business okay
please don't do any more videos I
haven't done video you know five years
every day yes I was the one it was a run
also I let us down but thank you very
much thank you for recognizing thanks
for watching Goods also thank you so
thank you for going over here thank you
hello I bought it how are you guys doing
here
okay such a pleasure it's very nice it's
my first time Wow oh no it's even better
it's my first time in Asia no not at all
hiya yeah you know a mix of serendipity
and just focusing on you know the proper
timing and making every second counts
I've been really looking forward to it
and it's been it's been so pent up that
when we landed in in baggage claim we
weren't even out of baggage claim I
looked at do you rock and I'm like this
is where I'm going to like this place
it's been it's been such a remarkable to
an a phase like I can't wait to come
back level of gratitude for
entrepreneurship and what it's done for
me and my family the energy in this
marketplace in this region in general I
think I associate with more a little bit
even more than I would say that then I
associated with the US and definitely
Europe's version of it so that yeah I
mean I grew up in the wine business I've
spent a lot of time in Europe the
rawness - the entrepreneurial spirit is
intoxicating for me and so I would think
that's probably a thing that it stood
out the you know the most I don't tell
you another thing and I am quite
passionate around having really
important conversations with young
entrepreneurs around family dynamics and
I think the one of the things I'm most
excited about obviously so much of my
strategy in coming to Asia is leading
with my content first I think I'm going
to be able to help a lot of kids have
difficult conversations with their
parents that in a 50-year macro will be
enormous ly beneficial but because
there's a lot of pressure in the Asian
ecosystem around education or doing the
right thing
and and and I'm very empathetic to that
migrate migrate moment of my life I
would actually argue is the fact that
even though I was an immigrant in the
u.s. my mom had enough self-esteem to
support me being a bad student which
which became the foundation of my
success
unconditional lovin and really
predicated on enormous self-confidence
in my mom that she knew what she was
doing parenting and didn't need to
follow the blueprint because a lot of
this has to do with insecurities of the
parents so yes some interesting things I
picked up on already when you get on it
I think a little bit of a level of a
chip on your shoulder great wild wild
west land grab opportunity maybe maybe
even a inch or two of like doing it at
all cost a little less a little less
polish a little less process
results-oriented one of the things that
was fearful is an admiration of Silicon
Valley culture which I think over time
is a negative for the region because
then you start building financial
arbitrage machines not actual businesses
so yeah just a little bit more but like
it just generally a little bit more of a
go-to attitude
yeah like the questions the tonality
even the way I'm being pitched and I
know what's interesting what I'm trying
to figure out is
what's the is there a chip on the
shoulder to a US Silicon Valley centric
thing which which I think there should
be in a place where especially when you
look at mainland China
you know those companies there's there's
so much further ahead in a lot of ways
because of their full integration I know
just there's a clearly different tone
which my early intuition leads to good
with my other intuition which is there's
too much looking at other places and
it's get well I think Asia should get
more insular because I think the natural
behaviors are better
[Music]
if they tried to convey that time -
never
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a dividend very sublime Logan usual oh
wow thank you master
what people love illusive thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I know it's hard to face up to the facts
but you must react just goes away
that doesn't mean you change
[Music]